ich versuche ja ob ich ein reifen
erwischt aber ich schaue gar nicht mehr
nach vorne doch eigentlich fahrer stand
und der zweite auf der alten ein nein
nein es geht und herzlich willkommen zur
ersten folge geht der online
ich sitze hier neben mir meine bewohner
lorenz ihre besondere lauf ich haben
kopfhörer auf und wir geben gas im
verzerren
niemand weiß wie sie geht ja jetzt wie
bei uns hier aussehen wird auf dem kanal
ich werde ich irgendwas
zusammenschneiden missionen rennen alles
was es gibt so das witzigste euch ja
übrigens leute macht auch challenges und
wenn wir gerade schon mal eine mission
ich habe gesagt das radio lieber
ausmachen wie kostete copyright will ich
sagen so wurde schon lück copyright sagt
wir machen eine chance also sprichst
alles französisch ok alles dabei spielen
die mission zum beispiel ich bin jetzt
kiste an der küste durch spiele hier ist
logistisch und wir machen es schwierig
gerade 1,5 schwer für mich spielen
schwer aber ich spiele einen bigos ich
bin ne gts gelernt viel spaß so
rotterdam sem seo wir nehmen wir den
speziell kwh was ich erzähle ich hab
schon eine weile geht hinein gespielt
man kann das jetzt auf level 42 ein
bisschen kollegen von mir dann jetzt
hier zum essen wird und man sich einfach
nicht für die sonnenbrille ok dazu
erwischt
und jetzt fahren wir darunter da unten
steht scheinbar ein lastwagen als wir
müssen der missionen lastwagen stehen
und irgendwo hinbringen der steht wohl
da unten sitzt da unten links auf der
minimap da unten ist die eingeblendet da
ist der last war zudem jetzt müssen so
ich habe vorgestern noch so der war
obligatorisch für alles schon aus aber
ich werde das nachholen jetzt als
allererstes wir packen unsere auto
wieder besser aussehen also wieso urlaub
machen wir damit mal okay sniper raus
ganz klassisch und jetzt machen wir
jetzt zeigen heute zeigen wie man
familien oder macht bei uns gibt einfach
keine hätte aber so kanns noch hinaus
glaubt ist so schwierig ist zu geben
kann ich kaum etwas scheint sich darüber
mokiert mehrfach einschießen because
darum müssen die dänen lassen die ihr
hier seht ihr mich bin stark dass der
lastwagen eventuell nicht mehr den mut
ich treffe es egal ich stelle wieder die
familie coach darunter wird
die aus die sonnenbrille hat mich fertig
weiß was ich dir jetzt ab ich muss dir
losgekommen der ich sehe nichts ich kann
so nicht ganz richtig softbox mit voller
härte
naja
anleger kalte schnauze diese nacht nach
fakten her kommen
das macht
lauterjung richtiger mit seinem fuß
einfach er hatte nur eine schwachstelle
seinen fuß komm du [ __ ] und genau die
muss ich nach laden der zu viel glück
wie einfach komisch was deine arme auf
den arm zu stehen
ich treffe ihn die ganze zeit ist jetzt
habe ich ihn erwischt und auch ein
bisschen regen wie eine stadt in bayern
angeblich ist hier noch ein gegner
ich würde sagen am donnerstag vor zwei
optische raketenwerfer der letzte kick
natürlich geht erstmal hier drüben mehr
das schild steht cecchetti hier war dann
kann ich denn damit mehr verkehren
sebastian
kaum was mit dir irgendwo ist reiner ich
weiß nicht wer der letzte ist aber hier
ist leider sind aber zwei
denn die erkenntnis der letzten position
ist nicht dein ernst alter immer noch
einen raketenwerfer junge das ist so
kann ich von hier muss machen warte
warte warte warte warte warte der
austria sicher nicht so
ok dann besser
ja genau gehabt dass vielleicht nicht so
schlau so das hat ihr kind und was unter
tel
junge ergebnis gekostet hat
wahrscheinlich mehr als eine katze
mission hier einbringen alter schwede
ein guter vergleich gezielt ja ja das
ist schwierig man aufnahmesituation ich
hab' ich hab mich seit von echten es
gibt da so aber in der aufnahme ist ein
bisschen anders so jetzt statt 19 lkw
hier fällig das sind wie eingesammelt
ein gesagt im inventar tor ist er sehr
hosentasche der lkw rucksack in sydney
gibt es bei den pokémon kein fahrrad und
lastwagen sportwagen alles okay manchmal
die scheinwerfer aus damit er nicht
finden
sorgen sich dann alles man ja ich weiß
ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß
ok ok oder studiert okay das sind zwei
stück ich bleibe arbeit hat das problem
dass sie alleine bin aber dem problem
kann ich entgegenwirken indem ich jeden
von den beiden da ein mp magazin in den
körper pumpen
das problem wird gleich auf der straße
diese diese typisierung kennt man ja
oder auf der straße dann ist mit dem
vater von vectone muss dann kommen die
ganzen gegnerischen autos post auf ihr
werdet sehen die straße hartmann straße
es wird völlig okay das licht ist ja
echt ganz neues werk oder ok dann links
auf dem radar die roten punkte
das sind die gegner wo gott ich drücke
mich einfach ich drücke mich und
versuche man kann nämlich wenn man auf
der computex drückt sieht man seinen
eigenen kopf biss hinein und wird dann
kaum betroffen oder weniger getroffen
was die jeweils so viel gas
egal ob deshalb probleme muss es war
geben du kannst du fährst allein lkw und
ballast nebenbei noch rückwärts mit der
imperia aus und kids die leute da das
hat gemeint ich von ihm verlange ich
hoffe ich mich dafür ein bisschen kohle
jeden tag tony hawk eye care zum abdruck
ist ja okay okay
wow gegen feuer gegen feuer gegen feuer
gegen feuer gegen feuer als die frau
sich weiter und du musst auf gps und den
jahren könnten auch überhaupt nicht
leiden
sehr schön was dieses match habe ich oft
nach den kleinen stapel
ok ich hab' beide hettiger ich wollte
ich wollte gerade kommt ich wollte ich
weiß nicht ob man das gefährt en
ich wollte ganz rechts abbiegen aber da
waren auto rechts von mir was mich davon
abgehalten hat er hätte so rechts an mir
geklebt schiff egal weil er jetzt sind
es als als easy und da kommen die
nächsten kopf und oder cookies hier das
kopf runter so ist kopf hoch so ein
bisschen wie man mit einem kopfball
hupen minuten aufgeben egal ich weiß
nicht ob ich okay
sieht ganz gut aus da hinten kommende
hugh jackman schneller sind sie kommen
jetzt auch oder nicht moment naja ich
glaube wenn man auf die minimap streckt
er muss jetzt wieder rechts ab ich war
relativ weit ist es dennoch
wahrscheinlich blick doch mal auf der
autobahn die parkschützer kommt über 200
sache und oft das sind wieder kopf
runter kopfunter kopf und da kommt ein
mann kommt der akku bei den lkw von
hinten an der sieht auch eine käserei
beamten buchstaben einfach kein mit
kugeln leute könnt ihr bitte nester
reinschreiben wäre echt nett von euch
wenn ihr schon drauf steht vielleicht um
die herzen auch oder soja oder dreieck
und ok da kommen die alte der woche zu
unfairen m
versuche die harten reifen erwischt ich
will schon gar nicht mehr nach vorne des
fahrers und der zweite alter talking ja
nein nein nein nein
was das gibt's doch nicht einspringen wo
mein gott es gibt es echt nicht okay es
klar gute sache so weit waren jetzt auch
schon mal warnt auch schon über die
kreuzung darüber hinaus steht also keine
lkw abliefern
von dem patzer von dem der un-mission
gegeben hat gehen wir doch ärger weißt
du ich weiß ich weiß ich werde ja doch
immer ich hoffe es kommt entscheidet das
navi wählten straßen kommt er nochmal
kommt dann noch jemand ich schließe man
so lange auf die anderen ja erwischt du
wolltest von munition ach komm ich will
sich wie sein leid beenden kommt stürmer
war ja ja ja die gab wichtig
das tier war logisch wertvolle
verantworten musste jugend unterhalt
genau leute hast du machst es beim
autohaus sollte jemals autofahren oder
lkw schon immer nach hinten und ballert
mit der empirum das ist mein tipp an
euch dann kann euch quasi nichts
passiert wenn es jetzt ein amerikaner
macht weil das gesagt hast dann verklagt
er dich und du musst dem geld seiner
wahrscheinlich sogar sie ja wie kann er
da vorne ja oder nein
ja doch davon ist natürlich okay
allerdings können wir ein und danfoss
conti cross country lkw mann ein
spezialist
disziplin oben rechts rum sogar das
wendekreis kurz zurück gesetzt alles
kein ding
oder ist es beliefert so dass von der
ersten folge geht ja wenn durchgefallen
hat lasse gerne daumen nach oben da
unbedingt auch eure
verbesserungsvorschläge in die
kommentare
wie würdet ihr euch gerne das projekt
hier wünschen geht soll das mit anderen
zusammen heißt sein sondern dass miranda
zusammen missionen sein
es wird auf jeden fall mit anderen
zusammen stattfinden ich hab jetzt
einfach nur die als mission war alleine
gezockt war lohan saß noch da nein das
war es von heute leute wir sind bei der
nächsten folge wieder